hey 42 here earthworms have five hearts
welcome to RIT for a million years the
human population of the earth was less
than 26,000 alkapone business card said
that he was a used furniture dealer half
of all the species in the world live in
the rainforest canopy the first world
war officially ended on the 3rd of
October 2010 after Germany had finally
finished paying off the last of its war
reparations drempt
is the only English word that ends in
the letters MT a man spent 17 years
building a Lamborghini from scratch in
his basement and then smashed a hole in
his house to get it out every day plants
convert sunlight into energy equivalent
to 6 times the entire power consumption
of human civilization your stomach has
to produce a new layer of mucus every
two weeks otherwise it will digest
itself in most advertisements the time
displayed on a watch is 10 past 10 it is
possible to drown without dying
the term drowning refers to the process
of taking water into the lungs not death
caused by that process every time you
lick a stamp you consume 1/10 of a
coloring Hershey's kisses are called
that because the machine that makes them
looks like it's kissing the conveyor
belt during World War two an American
pilot fell 20,000 feet without a
parachute before smashing through the
glass roof of a train station he
survived and lived to be 82 Nutella was
invented during World War two when an
Italian pastry maker mixed hazelnuts
into chocolate to extend his chocolate
ration 90% of the world's population
lives in the northern hemisphere thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2